hey guys guess what because I love you
so much I ran through the entire game
again I had to walk through here I dated
everything right and I'm gonna get the
best ending just because I know some
people would kill me if I did
so it didn't take that long I was um I
remembered everything I needed to do and
I had the walk through here to guide me
on my way so I got him haha oh man
big-time good for you guys but I'm happy
to do it so this they said this is where
things will change because you'll you'll
you'll see if you don't know the good
good ending uh you'll see how things
will change maybe if I did everything
right if I missed something I'm going to
be so upset thumb thumb thumb loser
Chloe you okay I gotta go I'm just gonna
go now
you're definitely supposed to burn this
bye bye push push
oh well she operated into a pile of ash
doot doot doot da da da da okay oh I
have to say girls - can't be scary
you can well anyway it burned up a lot
more violently glass shattered my hand
oh you're right I cut it
BAM be different I didn't even notice it
might have just happened is the minor
give hand kerchief that is what I am
supposed to do ah a hand kerchief may I
use it on my hand
isn't this real ace well I don't
particularly want to tarnish this too
late unfortunately oh well I'll borrow
this anyway thanks EEB let's get going
good friend alright so that is the most
important thing and I again I don't want
to tell exactly why cuz I'll be things I
don't know if I'll be spoiling anything
but you you can you I've done this I'm
gonna let it all play out because
frankly all those gonna happen
maybe maybe not I really I did a little
bit of movie and I may be stub out
stealing's gonna be dot perfect but I've
opened it boat B because you're gonna be
zipped up do brows what is that
wait a minute was this here before what
is this
I feel like I passed these stairs before
Eber you going out what is this what is
this what is this no water in the FA's
wait a minute oh this is where he came
down okay excuse me pardon me this is
where he came down oh this is so cool
Dave here I think I got a secret ending
I think I got us a grid ride cuz I
played the gate wool was that a sleeping
snake a snake it's a snake Cohen snake
what is this oh my god this is amazing
it's like whole new level cool so why
I'm actually kind of weirded out I
didn't see anything about this in the
walkthrough I'm a white and can't cross
this hole I want to go home spectacle of
blood excuse you
hey um can I use the coffee to wake it
up how did I just grab this come a copy
um can I just can can I have that can I
have that could I please have that
apparently not okay so how do I get
across this chasm what Wow isn't this
just fantastic what am I supposed to do
what am I supposed to do well I've
gotten to the secret area and now I am
totally lost sealed secret a concealed
secret a oh isn't this just lovely
I mother of God
you got to be gay me come all this way
to try to find the ending I find more
game
I would think I would think gonna be oh
wait whoa oh here we go
I just got a look at it twice cuz of the
ant the ant I just played through it
again I know this the ant listen hey
there's my home who do you down for me
boy I'll just be going home then good
boy and there we go
dancing flowers I'm whoa son of a [ __ ]
you murdered me dead how could you do
how could you
I'm so angry at you oh well didn't I
stay with the other one
dr. dad talk to the aunt
go get the painting blah blah blah get
it on get it in get it over
I should pay attention to the things
that I look at I mean it didn't say
anthill in the beginning but hole in the
ground should have made two plus doing
it no that's not even close to what it's
gonna be auto ski go home go home loo
deuce alright so I'm not supposed to be
able to go that way place out of reach
play with him just a murdering bastard
stirred up a blank slate clock never
seen one so big doesn't matter much what
the black thing in the middle is Oh
my heart goes to art my spirit goes to
creation mistake huh yeah oh I see what
it is
OOP nangou give me Oh bingo gimme oh I
got me
what is that then a black rose Oh
imprisoned flame butterfly might as well
I guess I don't think this will affect
the ending at all I think this is more
stuff unless this gets me to like a
secret ending I don't know kind of
confess I'm a little confused butterfly
flew away place will do that I was idle
to know I supposed to get back there so
I'm assuming I was supposed to let the
butterfly out now it's all flippy
floppies flew too floaty observe catch
it yeah caught the butterfly now
although I do about that
Wow jeez what are you you look like Lu
pull tail should we what if it wakes up
so uh what about that Oh what did I do
that
oh I see why I did that then let me go
back oh I see okay so I got the
butterfly do I put the butterfly
somewhere what's in here
Gary's got his dusty lighter
sorry looks like I ran out of oil will
leave for now we wouldn't want to be
ambushed here you don't know what's in
there what no the butterfly butterfly
flew away
get a tighter grasp on your butter Frey
oh it went to the light well what do I
owe I go on the dark room with the
candle baiting now things are clicking
now we're banging on all cylinders ah
this doesn't look safe I don't like this
I was wondering if there was gonna be a
part like this in the oh whoa oh okay
this is cameras nine god damnit couple
write things down again perp
nine you got it buddy you got green
you're n1 you got it
you want the ultra deluxe combo you
gonna cat it was this blue to BL you to
blue you two with me
then blue me hold up channel oh my
I saw those something else I didn't
think that was grapes I thought that was
bad okay that's the other thing our good
luck god damn it the hell was that ha ha
ha Gary screams Gary er did I say I
don't think it matters right now would
it matter
alarm for the clock
okay fly back flipper baby what does
that do
relent do yellow why lw3 okey-dokey
what do i do with all these numbers
malice is true form
the master I want to see malice this
true form
oh wow whoo-whoo-whoo it wasn't all that
scary
Oh at first I was like ooh and then I
was like yeah that didn't sound good
I think mouse's true form kind of went
away read German I think mouths is
before game off the wall
it won't not be diggin open letter
opener bellows history for him Oh
oh I got a bad feeling about okay we get
outta here look at Eddie
okay now haha
true ants second dance ah here we go
wait how do I know what color go to what
thing maybe this colors of the rainbow
there'd be nine funny what direction it
goes oh one huh uh a few maybe the other
way hmm maybe I'm not kidding it right
prolly not maybe I'm forgetting my
colors of the rainbow I wouldn't doubt
it I wouldn't doubt it
nope I'm wrong how am I supposed to know
and what happened you Mouse is I'm gonna
save before I confront Mouse's true form
just gonna say that right now I don't
want to do any of do that so hey what is
this hard to wake man you know what I
mean this is gonna be a whole nother
part geez how do I get over there how do
I get to there how do I get over to Lou
there I want to go there but I did as a
whole this crack in the ground I think
and now there's this I may be one of the
other paintings like sad damn don't know
oh I got the heebie jeebies in here whoa
what is this what is this what is this
is the thing I saw I didn't get a good
look at it what is it what is it what is
this thing
our fragments of something what of what
of why really the wine
is that a clue grape was purple
I don't know red came first
huh let's switch dollars for the clock
damn it
confused dammit
I don't know what's going
and I don't know where the read malice
thing is but it appear to be here
I think it has left the building taken
what am i small the paintings on the
other wall the paintings over there in a
red blue yellow purple green red blue
yellow purple green ah red blue yellow
purple green Oh genius house oh okay
there we go
Hey oh that's now what I wanted whoa
butterfly butterfly what am i I did it
oh you did you yeah get away from me
you lanky bastard so what do I why was
that necessary
oh they'll sleep hey what are you doing
out of your home no not you I don't want
you I'm hungry I want something to eat
something sweet look great well I don't
know about that locked locked what do
you mean it's locked I want to go to the
theme
ah Jesus where'd you come from
eat eat him eat him eat him oh I thought
it was gonna eat him I thought it was
gonna eat him dad
okay then well then I still don't know
how to get to there oh it can't come
directly at us cuz you can't see us but
it go over there why is it over there
what is it what is it doing are you
doing more here man hey Benny did
are you joined what do I do about you
what's this practical blood over here
man I would get this I need to give this
guy something neat give kid I never ate
my candy do I give him the candy should
I give him the candy I never even had a
knob to be the candy but here's candy
are you really gonna give it that I mean
that's fine but I don't want to eat this
ah looking bikini they're good enough
for you
hey I actually thought that was gonna be
some maybe a get something from these
flowers no nope yeah do I still have
that piece of candy okay good good good
good good
we don't have our light so let's not go
in here oh well screw you you big baby
okay turn Hey No what do I do
what do we do how do I do
I don't know what to do i but i effed up
III effed up
I asked up bad how do I get it back to
this place I don't know I do there's
something else up here I don't think so
uh what about that
it's a very pleasant holy ha ha ha ha ha
was that start of Stardust do I feed
this to the ant is this sweet I don't
know it's pretty cool but I don't know
about sweet whoa that is the red of pure
malice I'm gonna go the other way thank
you very much ha ha ha you like just
sitting there yeah yeah we're where you
are come on oh come on
Jesus why yo
here have some Stardust it's more like
can't even star to me wait a moment
I'm a waiting gift oh you got me the key
you were so nice what about this red
Mallis red head lies on the ground yes
yeah as normal ok you gonna you gotta
get the F out of my way you dick you
[ __ ] all of l'a God you're gonna
cause problem for me there we go got it
the hell is all Queen of high society I
mean man
Oh what happened
what I do know do an elated woman down
in the abyss what abyss whose abyss
you mean the oh my damn this is like a
whole nother game going on her the lower
part that's a real frame they're both
wearing real clothes I wonder how long
he must have taken to make this a long
time where Tina was an amazing psycho
what a damn good artist whoa oh my oh my
what
ha 20 the top you out there what am I
supposed to do here what could this be a
painting I paint a piece of painting
this is like a whole dollar game huh
interesting
oh boy red chase black okay
there are gotcha breath yeah sweet
Rick Oh get out of here red
are you are you hey come back here
hi come back here got you got you monkey
what's wrong with red by the way but red
always get a bad rap great you little
rapscallions I'm gonna get y'all yeah
I'm gonna get you all yet no you come
back here you little yellow barber yeah
that's right you shouldn't run away from
me ow
oh wow wow no no oh wow wow Jesus why
you got to be so douche your ask how am
i how am I ever gonna catch that one now
that one was great God dingus thing okay
there we go I got him how was I ever
gonna get another one of your twist
bastards
yeah that coin yeah that corner I see
this is actually quite not I would come
again did I get them all I think I did
wait no but stick people in poop a bit
about it about vamoosh key all right
what did that do um well okay what was
the point of that oh there we go yeah I
thought I saw that but it didn't pick it
up before oh here we are
ah I'm collecting pieces of a painting
oh don't kill me I haven't saved there's
no water in the vase Oh what hello
little birdie it's coming along okay oh
you're more than welcome to can't
promise safety though uh okay
so we got um things here maze of cacti
awfully dangerous Gary I don't think you
should go alone Gary we will go together
and we will make it through we'll go
together never separate okay I died oh
wow all right then well now isn't that
something actually what I'm gonna do is
I'm gonna cut it here obviously there's
more game to play and I still have to
get to the other endings dope um this
theory the series carries on thank you
all so much for watching click the
annotation for more videos that I've
done and as always I will see you in the
next video
I shall dispose of the remaining
myself she looks kind of creepy oh that
can wait
Mario
god
well
Oh
she's aware of what
god I don't believe
that is the problem the girl will be 11
soon
oh sure